for months ukraine's stages and theaters
have been closed because of war but
slowly they're coming back
[Applause]
despite war we believe that cultural
institutions should operate if it's
possible it's both important for the
public for them to attend
defending their land ukrainians are also
in a fight to preserve their cultural
identity war is about identity
it's about
russian's idea that ukrainian identity
does not exist and ukrainians do not
exist as
as a separate society it's a view openly
held by russia's president vladimir
putin russian
propaganda machine works that ukraine do
not have their culture they do not have
their history they don't have their
national and cultural identity so it
should be destroyed it should be shelled
it should be looted
that's what happened in parts of ukraine
since the invasion museums and galleries
and other national treasures have been
targets it's obviously a war crime and
crime against humanity ukrainians are
resisting to defend their culture just
as their military is resisting to defend
the country
this new contemporary art exhibit is
provoking ukrainians to express
themselves including how they feel about
the war people should
fail and
should speak about their feelings and
this exhibition is about that
outside the recently reopened opera
house in keeve on a saturday afternoon
patrons have come to see the ballet
this woman gets emotional she says she's
here because her grandson's fighting in
the war she needed an escape others are
making a point of showing defiance also
russians wants to destroy our culture
and our language and
we want to do everything to support it
to defend it they want to steal
everything from mezzo soprano katarina
simbaluk a plea to defend culture and to
keep supporting her country ukraine now
as a shield of all europe because nobody
knows if we will not stop putin here in
ukraine we don't know
how far he can go he will not stop and
ukrainians say they won't stop doing
what they can to preserve their culture
shawn o'shea global news kharkiv